[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and what
better way to break out of the box than
with a car video can't really think of a
better way uh so i'm obviously not a car
reviewer i've never even really shown
that i'm interested
in cars any more than the super sweet
ones that anyone likes anyway but i do
appreciate a good car and when tesla
offered me the opportunity to check out
the tesla model s for the day i couldn't
really say no to that so without any
further ado it's my first car video
these are the top five tech features in
the tesla model s
[Music]
so spoiler i've never actually owned a
car i've always lived close enough to
the school i go to my whole life that
i've never actually needed to own a car
but even through all that this car and
all the tech inside keeps catching my
eye and of course it's a car that's been
in the news a lot sure but i don't think
there's any doubt that this is one of
the most modern cars of this generation
so of course there's a lot of tech
inside to talk about
[Music]
so number five is the sound system and
that's actually the one thing i couldn't
get on camera to demo for you guys while
i was messing with the car but uh to
make a long story short it sounds
fantastic now this is a really quiet car
obviously there's no engine noise and
it's a really really tightly isolated
cabin the acoustics are actually
fantastic and with the tech package that
i'll talk about later in this video and
the fantastic speakers it sounds great
to sit in the driver's seat position the
audio exactly where it should be
and just listen to your music on top of
that it hooks up your phone actually via
bluetooth
there was no auxiliary jack no three and
a half millimeter headphone deck to just
plug in a pair of like and maybe an ipod
or something like that so i guess that
was the biggest con maybe of the whole
car but the fact that it has a pretty
sweet sound system hooks up via
bluetooth uh it's pretty great so that
brings description number four and that
is the design of this car now i happen
to think it's actually a really good
looking car but it has a point it's
actually very pretty in that way for a
reason so this model s is a striking car
obviously it resembles a lot of other
bodies out there some jaguar some aston
martin some maserati even there's a
little bit of each of those in the
design of this car but in case you
didn't already know it's all electric
and a big part of getting the best range
out of the batteries is efficiency and
with its shape the model s has a
ridiculously low drag coefficient of
0.24 which is actually the lowest of any
car which means it's going to cut
through the air with the least amount of
wind resistance basically it's
technically a hatchback but it still has
that aggressive profile and low center
of gravity because all the batteries are
on the floor of the car
and it has a completely flat bottom so
there's no transmission or anything
sticking out the bottom and interrupting
airflow the design all is here with a
purpose to keep the car cutting through
the air also this is the highest end 85
kilowatt hour performance plus model so
with this you can grab a tech package
and get a carbon fiber spoiler on the
back that even further improves airflow
and even besides airflow this car is
really well designed inside and out and
that's another thing we'll get to in a
second this also isn't the first
iteration of the model s it's gotten a
few hardware tweaks since it first came
out and one of those little hardware
tweaks was folding mirrors and that's
actually pretty big cars so you'll kind
of need those in new york and like a
cherry on top for the design when you
unlock the car the mirrors and door
handles unfold which brings us right to
number three
the key
this
is the key for unlocking the tesla model
s it's a mini model s it actually has
some hot spots uh on the key to let you
unlock doors uh lock the doors or even
completely open the hatchback to give
you access to the trunk it has rfid tags
inside so when you get up to the handles
you get close enough to the car they'll
automatically deploy the handles for you
so really out of all the car keys i've
seen even from supercars i've seen this
one i mean it's it's a mini version of
the car it's really cool uh it's the
closest thing to a smartphone gimmick
about this car that i can think of it's
something that you can demo to someone
live and they'll instantly remember it
so i guess what i'm trying to say here
is show me a cooler key of a car and
i'll be impressed i was really happy
about the way the key looks on the model
s anyway number two uh which is arguably
straight strictly car tech but i would
call the tech of the car anyway it's the
electric motor that powers the entire
model s this thing is a beast so when i
visited tesla to check this car out they
had the frame of a model s on display in
there showing the tray where the
thousands of batteries sit and the
suspension and the wheels and the
electric motor right there that little
guy that is what powers this car and
makes it absolutely fly so like i said i
got to mess with the highest end 85
kilowatt hour performance plus model and
i got to drive it and well it's pretty
awesome so it sports a 0 to 60 time of
4.2 seconds so that's gonna give you a
pretty idea of how lightning quick it is
off the line and it's an electric car so
it has all of the torque available
immediately as soon as you touch the gas
pedal not the gas pedal though the go
pedal it's a very different feeling
versus the normal lag you have between
stomping on the gas pedal of a gas car
and actually accelerating so that
instant torque makes this car so much
fun to drive so the 0 to 40 time is
obviously really impressive and it puts
you in the backyard seat when you're
flying but the thing is so is the 40 to
60 time and that also allows you to put
you in the back your seat and while i
didn't have the roads in new york to
test this 60 to 80 mile an hour time but
i'm sure that too would have been
awesome best way to describe the instant
torque is it feels like a roller coaster
launch when the tires stick this car is
really something else now there are also
some other benefits of being electric
for one there is almost nothing under
the hood to maintain in this car you pop
the front trunk of course using your
fancy key and you will see well that's
exactly what it is a front trunk all you
have to maintain is just windshield
wiper fluid that's it so you have a
pretty sizable front trunk they call a
frunk
and that's i guess what the people of
tesla call it you know the electric
motor in the back is also so small that
you really have tons and tons of space
in the back again it's a hatchback style
but it's a big sedan and this car has
significantly more space than any other
car its size i mean if you put the seats
down you can fit probably like eight
golf bags in the back of this car it's
just massive so the batteries are also
on the floor so you have headroom for
days a big open space where the
transmission and gearbox would normally
be i mean there are so many spaces
opened up by not having a gas engine and
a gas tank and all the maintenance that
comes with that stuff oh and the cherry
on top of all that driving this car it
is completely silent
that's right
so that brings us to the number one best
part of the tech inside this car and i
think it's pretty obvious at this point
the number one is the center console it
is a 17 inch touchscreen in the center
of the the console of the car that
replaces all the buttons and dials and
knobs that you'd find in basically any
other car
it's the number one head turner it's the
number one thing people talk about when
i was at ces and people were looking
inside the car that's the number one
thing that they talked about the center
console on the model s is really
impressive it's big enough and high
enough resolution to control literally
everything about the car and it's
running a custom built os from tesla
that can get free over-the-air updates
over the 3g connection included in the
car
that actually adds functionality every
time they update the car so the latest
one was memory seats they just added it
with an update so yeah this is an
internet connected car basically with a
giant 17-inch 1080p tablet in the center
not the highest pixel density but still
packing way more pixels than probably
any other car i'm sure so in terms of
functionality you have your energy
tracking for the battery usage the media
playback controls for your phone audio
or radio
and you have google maps navigation
which i'd say is probably the most
trustworthy at any time and you can swap
these in any configuration top to bottom
or even make one of them full screen
whenever you want and last but not least
you have a full html web browser so
there's no flash so it won't play
youtube video or stream audio from any
website but you can totally have your
passenger look up the score of a game on
the center console if his phone is dead
or something he can always access the
internet there
so yeah then in the bar at the bottom
you have the stuff that doesn't ever
move so it kind of becomes muscle memory
it's always there that stuff replaces
the typical knobs for your audio volume
and climate control temperature so you
can also control more physical parts of
the car through the touch screen like
the sunroof which literally just lets
you drag an image of the car the sunroof
to whatever percentage you want just to
open it with dragging the touchscreen
it's crazy convenient and pretty quick
too and you also have a rear-facing
wide-angle backup camera on the car it
turns on automatically when you're in
reverse or you can turn it on yourself
whenever you want and it's decent
quality it's actually pretty good i
might start doing some reviews with it
or maybe not so yeah this thing is fully
featured basically the number one
question people have when they see this
huge screen in the car is is it
distracting while you're driving uh and
i would say not really it was on auto
brightness and i got used to it pretty
quickly i was the only one i was driving
for maybe an hour or two and i got used
to it and if you're driving at night it
switches into night mode and inverts a
lot of the colors but if you really need
to punch in directions while you're
driving using google maps you still have
your passenger do it since nothing gets
disabled while you're driving so all the
functionality is always available so
yeah you won't find anything like this
in any other car right now it's the
number one tech in the tesla model s for
sure
it's just one of those things like
front-facing speakers on a phone where
it feels like the future and i kind of
wish everyone else would adopt it so
there you go guys just a fun little
video on the tesla model s i figured i'd
share the experience with you guys and i
also have more stuff coming up with
tesla and hopefully other car stuff too
along with the other stuff i'm breaking
out of so again stay tuned here if you
want to see more stuff like that and let
me know what you guys think of the model
s i mean obviously it's an electric car
so there's gonna be the people who just
don't like electric cars the range
anxiety bothers people for me personally
the biggest con of the car i think is a
lack of an audio jack
but again it's a highly acclaimed car
with the all the awards it's won and the
the motor trend car the year and the
highest ratings on safety tests all that
kind of stuff is doing really well so
either way thanks for watching that's
been it i hope to talk to you guys in
the next one see you then peace
[Music]
you